[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
arraignment day
again
[Music]
twice in Peach Thrice indicted and
arrested
he will be arrested today he will be
digitally fingerprinted the word is is
that they will use a prior photo
of the Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa
poopy pants
himself for his attempt and his arrest
for his attempt to overthrow our
government with a plot of the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup
is accountability coming this morning we
will see it won't take long to arraign
him on these charges like I said maybe
15-20 minutes it'll take longer for that
fat slob to walk into the processing
room and then down to the courtroom
where he will be arraigned then probably
the arraignment himself itself he's
definitely not going to want to hear the
45 pages read out loud to him he
probably hasn't read them doesn't want
to read them and the reason why is
because it lays out his demise his legal
and criminal demise
Jack Smith
has absolutely undercut every single one
of Donald Trump's ridiculous
delusional legal defenses including the
the first amendment I have the freedom
of speech which is not a thing
you do have the right to say whatever
you want to say but you don't have the
right inaction of a conspiracy to
overthrow our elections to overthrow our
government to deep fraud the United
States of America using your official
office of President of the United States
or the like
Donald Trump is in big big trouble here
with
the doj not with his supporters by God I
mean he's he's just now posting on fraud
social that he's one more indictment
away from I don't know crowning himself
king or some [__] I think he I think he
really thinks these are like Awards
right Donald Trump always would make
like fake Time magazine covers and hang
that [__] up on his wall I think he
thinks indictments are like Grammys or
something
like he gives a speech and he's like I
want to thank I want to thank all the my
fellow coup plotters
I want to thank all the people that
participated in the coup attempt even
though it wasn't successful we still won
the indictment
what the [__]
these aren't flexes [__]
but he's going to continue with the
buffoonery it won't stop it's not going
to and you know I was talking to someone
this morning and they were saying maybe
he'll take a deal he's so far past a
deal it ain't even funny I can't even
imagine what deal Jack Smith could offer
him at this point
what what what the [__] would you offer
him
how could you make a deal with this
[__] idiot
there's no deal to be had
the only thing you could do is live out
the process here
it's one of my fears I I expressed it
yesterday A lot of people thought it was
dark my a block yesterday because I
wasn't jumping up and down and yelling
and screaming and cheering that he was
indicted again and indicted on January
on the coup plot which there's likely to
be more arraignments he's likely to be
arrested in Georgia soon maybe as soon
as next week
he could be arraigned in Georgia it
looks like they're preparing in Fulton
County to arrest Donald Trump and to
arraign him and others
Lindsey Graham Rudy Giuliani
speaking of Rudy Giuliani we found out
who the co-conspirator number six six
was six six whatever whatever it is
Trump you know you're famous they allow
you to do that
it's Boris Epstein our Epstein I don't
know it's Epstein Epstein
this [__] Russian
we talked about Boris here on the Tony
Michaels podcast before uh Boris was in
uh in Donald Trump's he was a close Ally
of Donald Trump he was one of the media
Talking Heads during the 2016 election
Boris is the scummiest of the scumbags
no [__] he is a scumbag
full stop
and a trump scumbag at that now Boris
when
he's such a scumbag he couldn't even
really hold a job in government under
Trump and the Trump Administration after
he won in 2016. so Boris had to go work
for sin clear broadcasting I don't know
if you know who Sinclair bought
broadcasting are but they're a
right-wing family that buys up all these
local news stations if you have a local
news station near you and it's owned by
Sinclair broadcasting it's it's likely
that they pump right-wing propaganda
right into your news into the headlines
into the [__]
because they're right Wingers
and at one point Boris Boris even had a
propaganda segment I'm not kidding you
Boris Johnson would do pro-trump
pro-russian propaganda segments and they
would make these local affiliate
stations that Sinclair owned make them
run them on their news
people got so tired of it that Sinclair
canceled it because there were so many
complaints
about Boris Epstein doing his little
propaganda videos it was [__] weird
it didn't last very long but it's
[__] weird
but Boris is apparently
that's what they say he's the
co-conspirator number six and again I'm
excited whoever it is I'm excited
whoever gets indicted in Georgia let's
do this [__] let's let's do it [__] it
it's about time we we point these people
and say you're [__] criminals
so now for this garbage this projection
like Jim Comer and Jim Jordan are doing
in the oversight and the weaponization
community
now we know
now we know that Devin Archer's
testimony was all bunch of [__]
theatrics and the reason why we know
this and I knew this from the very
[__] beginning I told you before
Devin Archer even even spoke a word in
the hearing I told you it's all [__]
that's the reason why they did a closed
door meeting and they just had it
transcribed I'm surprised that we're
even seeing the transcript now
Dan Goldman
the great congressman from New York
asked Devin Archer pointed questions
about Hunter Biden Joe Biden and berysma
and Devin Archer couldn't give one shred
not one shred of evidence that he knew
anything that was a foul not one the
only statement he made was that without
Hunter Biden barisma might go out of
business that's the only thing that he
could postulate and it was only his
personal opinion he didn't have evidence
of the fact
and we should we should we should we
should be glad that they're serious
people in our Congress like Dan Goldman
folks this is what it's all about this
is the difference between us and Them
and what I mean is people who want
democracy who want serious people making
our policy and protecting our country
from scumbag Traders like these
Republicans
in Dan Goldman
now am I gonna fly a Dan Goldman flag or
put a put a Dan Goldman hat on no
because we're not a [__] cult and you
don't need to be a cultist to understand
it takes serious people making serious
policy in our government to make sure
our country is serious not a [__]
clown show
like the Republican party is only going
to be seen as today when they continue
to defend Trump
when he's being arraigned on a coup
attempt
with hard evidence in the indictment
that yes he [__] knew he lost and it
doesn't matter what he said on that day
at the ellipse they're not charging him
with his speech they're charging him
with his [__] actions to try to
overthrow our election
Mike Pence and Bill Barr those [__]
cowards now just now it's August 3rd
2023 and they're just now acknowledging
what we all knew
yes Trump was gonna do anything
absolutely anything to stay in power
because he was desperate he is desperate
he's a desperate little man
and Mike Pence and Bill Barr finally
came around to telling the country what
they what we all knew they knew that
Donald Trump was trying to overthrow the
government of the United States Mike
Pence saying yesterday in front of
cameras
the president was gonna make me choose
between him and the Constitution yeah we
know
where were the Where Were You in [__]
December of 2020 huh Mike
you piece of [__] where were you in
December 2020 Bill Barr
you know the craziest part about it all
they're gonna vote for Trump
I ain't [__] you you're my favorite
turd I would not [__] you
Mike Pence and Bill Barr are gonna go
vote for Trump
that's how corrupt that's how cowardly
that's how delusional
that the Republican party has become
that even the ones who know for sure who
were in the room
When Donald Trump was trying to
overthrow your vote
and overthrow your country and become
the dictator in the king in the United
States of America
and they would do almost nothing to
stand in his way of doing that
besides their their own their own legal
peril
the only reason why Bill Barr and Mike
Pence did what they did is it because
they stand on principle
they're cowards they have no principle
the only reason why they did what they
did is because they're cowards because
they knew they would go to federal
prison if they did what Donald Trump
asked them to do
just like Rudy Giuliani John Eastman
Jeffrey Clark
Sydney Powell the Kraken cheese burrow
and Boris
and who knows how many in Georgia will
be roped into this just like he roped in
Walt T NADA and Carlos
everything Trump touches turns to liquid
[__]
absolute liquid [__] some say it dies I
say it turns to liquid [__]
oh
everything so many lawyers have lost the
ability to even practice law Mark
Meadows Mark Meadows is going to lose
his entire life over this
because he wouldn't say anything Mike
Pence can't even get one percent he was
the vice president of the United States
folks
he was Trump's lap dog licked his balls
every goddamn day of the week during the
Trump Administration and Beyond only
until now only until now Mike pencil
basically say yeah he was trying to
overthrow our government and I wouldn't
go along with his crime
come on
give me a break
Mike
but this is this is the trumpian way
this is the Republican Party they're
clowns
absolute 100 [__] clown speaking of
clowns oh my god this piece of news
Rhonda santis is a dumb [__] oh
my God have you heard this he actually
thinks he's going to debate Gavin Newsom
on Fox News
Ron DeSantis was like oh yeah sure I'll
do it on Fox News as if Ron desantis's
interviews have went anywhere but South
on Fox News I don't know why he thinks
Fox News is a is a safe haven for him
especially from Gavin Newsom I'm very
excited about this debate
and the reason why is the clips of Gavin
Newsom absolutely making Ron DeSantis
look like a meatball
battering him with the Biden Hammer
because that's what he's going to do
folks Gavin Newsom is going to smash
Rhonda Santos with the Biden hammer
I don't know if you've watched you have
a news some actually make Arguments for
the Democratic party but it's always led
by the Biden hammer
every single time Gavin Newsom knows
exactly what Joe Biden's record is he
knows exactly what Joe Biden has done
for the American people and Gavin Newsom
has fouled suit and tried to do just as
much or more in California
and I cannot tell you how excited I am
to watch Gavin Newsom absolutely
disembowel Ron DeSantis on a national
stage on what is to be a safe Network
maybe maybe those delusional old
[__] that watch that [__] maybe
just maybe maybe just maybe they'll get
a dose of what it really looks like to
be a [__] Patriot
because we know now we know now today
after this arrest if you are Donald
Trump or you support Donald Trump in any
shape or any form or fashion you are not
a patriot you are a [__] traitor
a [__] traitor to our nation you are
not a patriot I don't care how you
support him whether it's some social
media post rather it's you saying it out
loud are you voting for him you're a
[__] traitor to our country
and that's how we should see it
and that's how we should call it
balls and Strikes baby
you're a traitor it's really easy it's
really easy it's not hard after today
DeSantis is gonna
to make you have a new surprise dude
listen man
I know I'm not your campaign advisor and
honestly I won't charge you anything
just call me buddy I'll tell you all the
[__] you shouldn't do at least maybe not
the [__] you should be doing but the
[__] you shouldn't be doing
you're ruining your political career
and he's losing so badly in the
Republican primary he thinks debating
one of the best [__] one of the best
media Democrats out there Gavin Newsom
is going to help him what a [__]
idiot
what if I can't wait to watch Gavin
Newsom undress that [__] pudding
fingers
I hope Gavin Newsom brings up the
pudding too [__] him
anyways
Donald Trump is oh my God he's losing
his mind on fraud social this morning
uh and overnight he said
that he wants to have a federal takeover
of DC he's terrified
about a DC jury you know there's this
big [__] argument on the right that
oh oh you can't get a fair jury in DC
Trump will never get a fair jury in DC
well he shouldn't have committed crime
in Washington DC then
if he wanted a fair trial and a jury in
West Virginia he should have went and
committed crime in West Virginia then
that's how it works
that's how it's always worked you
[__] buffoons and let me tell you a
nice little fact here a nice little
factoid that'll help you
when you understand why Donald Trump is
going to get wadded up and dunked in the
[__] trash on this change of venue
not one not one January 6 defendant in
this entire process has ever won a
change of venue not one
not one
look
if if you want to be Tried by a jury in
a certain jurisdiction in this country
commit crime there you [__] idiot
do it there that will help like then
you'll then you'll have to get tried in
that jurisdiction
I don't know if you were gonna overthrow
the West Virginia capital or not or
commit a coup on West Virginia maybe I
don't know maybe that's your thought
maybe that's what you want to do but you
shouldn't have done it in DC
you should not have attempted a coup
in DC and you would be tried somewhere
else just like Mar-A-Lago you committed
crime in South Florida you were indicted
in the south Florida federal district
that's how it [__] works just like
Georgia you committed crime in Fulton
County Georgia guess where you're gonna
be indicted Fulton County Georgia
oh here's another one the Manhattan D.A
oh my God who would think if you
committed crime in Manhattan that you
would be Tried by a jury in Manhattan
who in the actual [__] is advising this
guy who the [__] is actually standing
around going you know what we should
commit crime and we should definitely do
it here because you'll won't get a fair
jury and then you can ask for a change
of venue this is dumb [__]
we are in the dumbest stupidest [__]
timeline possible we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and these people are actually out
on TV saying this [__] he should get a
change of value it's on fire in DC yeah
well it was unfair for him as president
United States to obstruct official
proceeding to defraud the United States
of America that seems a little unfair
and because he did it and I don't know
the District of Columbia that's where
he's gonna have his jury
how the F don't you have enough [__]
brain cells to rub the getter to
understand these things these are Easy
Legal Concepts you don't even have to be
a lawyer
you don't even have to Google the [__]
to know this stuff who the [__] doesn't
know you get tried for your crimes in
the district that you committed them
how in the [__] don't you have you seen
have you seen any crime show ever or
watched any kind of [__] murder
mystery or watch any kind of murder
documentaries ever in the history of
ever and you don't know this [__]
Jesus [__] Christ
but the arguments are gonna get dumber
and dumber and dumber and dumber and
dumber and the reason why is because
they don't have a real legal argument
they do not have one never had one never
will because it's outright overt blatant
crimes we know it they know it everyone
else knows it we just need to see the
evidence to make sure that Donald Trump
does not see the light of day
which brings me to the dark part of this
yes I have to say this over and over and
the reason why is because the mainstream
media is filling you full of a bunch of
misinformation I said it and I'll
continue to say it until they stop this
[__]
people are even talking about cameras in
a federal courtroom stop it stop with
the nonsense there hasn't been federal
judges that let cameras inside courtroom
stop with the fiction stop with the
misinformation oh well it's it's gonna
be the trial of the century we need to
have evidence there'll be plenty of
evidence just like there is evidence in
every other single criminal federal
trial stop making [__] up
stop it
people are trying to take you seriously
legal analysis on TV and I don't give a
[__] who they are and you can you tell
them to come to me and I'll [__] talk
to him personally I don't give a [__]
this idea that there's going to be
cameras inside this courtroom is a lie
it's misinformation
it is distraction it is to make you the
audience keep tuning in because you feel
good about what they're saying
it's nonsense
and the other thing too is there is
likely not to be a trial until after the
election yes I know Jack Smith is doing
everything he can to speed to a trial
but it's not Jack Smith's decision
that's not how it works it's never how
it's worked the prosecutor does not get
to decide when to try the defendant
ever never
so stop with the misinformation you can
say yeah Jack Smith appears to be
speeding this along
but it does it's not likely to see trial
before the election
oh but Tony there's there's a there's a
date set of for a trial for the
documents case before the election yes
it's been the third date that we've
heard about the third date that was
considered you don't think they're gonna
punt this thing again the other thing
that concerns me is in the conspiracy
charge
think about this think about this with
your own with your own mind
don't listen to what someone else tells
you because it makes you feel good
use your brain
in a conspiracy case in federal court it
is most of the time 99.9 percent of the
time that the co-conspirators are on the
exact same indictment
as all the other co-conspirators that's
why it's a conspiracy because they
conspired together
that is not the case in this indictment
that is not the case that is an outlying
fact
of what is normal
it is concerning
I trust what Jack Smith knows and what
Jack Smith
can do but it is concerning I see it as
something that will be used as a delay
tactic on Trump's defense
I think Jack Smith is trying to get to a
trial I really do but we the people
cannot count on doj and Jack Smith to
save our democracy that is up to us
the people we are the government we have
the power of the ballot we are Trump's
jury It Is Us
and we should act as much
we should not get distracted
about Hope of say someone else one man
Jack Smith saving our democracy that is
not how our democracy is designed
and that it's not how it'll play out you
must focus on what is important now in
this moment
we know he's indicted we know he's going
to be arrested we know there's going to
be superseding indictments in this case
because the guy can't shut his [__]
mouth
and he can't stop obstructing
so there's likely to be more
arraignments in this case and added
charges we definitely know there's going
to be an arrest in Georgia
it's becoming very clear that it's
eminent
but don't let that distract you from the
work of democracy we have a nation to
save
it is our nation and as Patriots real
Patriots who love their country who love
Liberty who love freedom who want
equality and equity for all it is our
job to stand and be Trump's jury now and
forever
we cannot rely on any jurisdiction on
any jury pool or any prosecutor to save
us
it is up to us we did the work in 2020
we did it in 2022 we will do it again in
2024.
let us not be distracted
let us do the work of democracy we have
Hal Sparks here today speaking of doing
the work of democracy Hal Sparks is
going to join us at the top of the hour
I'm super excited to have Hal you know
the audience our audience mine and Hal's
audience there's a lot of overlap we got
a lot of spark we got a huge audience
today there must be a ton of sparklers
in the chat here
and I welcome all the sparklers and what
you should do sparklers while you're at
it you should go ahead and subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast I know me and
Hal overlap a little bit on our live
broadcast but you can always come and
watch our show afterwards at least the
30 minute a block who doesn't want to
watch it Tony Michael's rant really
honestly come on even I get excited
about my own rants they're the best of
all time you can guaran goddamn tea that
so hit the like button or if you don't
like it I don't care you can hit the
dislike button too but make sure to get
into the comments and talk to the
[__] fam in the chat rather you love
me or you love to hate me you will love
when you subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast here on YouTube also you can
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels
you can watch it live over there every
single weekday we're live to all the new
viewers we are live every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific
we're also on Twitch at that time so if
you want to follow us on Twitch it's
free twitch.tv Tony Michaels we had a
ton of people re-subscribe with their
Amazon Prime account yesterday
holy moly those numbers are getting up
there I want to thank everyone over
there who uses their Amazon Prime
account to subscribe
to our Twitch account giving us a couple
extra dollars
of Amazon's money every single month and
it doesn't cost you the prime subscriber
any extra money
also you can you can download every
single episode which you should on Apple
Spotify and Google we release the audio
version
every single afternoon as long as I get
my [__] together
[Laughter]
that happens
sometimes so go to go to your favorite
directory and download every single
weekday the Tony Michaels podcast Apple
Spotify Google or your favorite
directory every single weekday I got
some clips to show you I've got some
clips to show you I want to talk to you
about the round table of democracy on
patreon but we're going to take a quick
break when we come back I'll show you
some clips at the top of the hour don't
go anywhere stay tight stay tight as
they say on radio Hal Sparks is going to
join us at the top of the hour we'll be
right back right after this we
right back Mark 60 seconds this is the
Tony Michaels podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
as I said at the top of the other we'll
have it how sparks shout out to all the
sparklers that are joining us today
check out Hal on these Tony Michaels
podcast
you know you guys are the ones who did
this the audience
you're going his chat coming my chat how
get on this show Tony in on his show
and maybe some know maybe some don't
know me and Hal know each other
I I don't think I've ever been on Hell
show and he's never been on mine we've
been on shows together on different
shows together and I actually had Hal as
a guest I believe once or twice while we
were doing the select hearings the
coverage of the select hearings for my
dis touch on their Channel
so if you're here in your sparkler
welcome welcome welcome if this is your
first time at the Tony Michaels podcast
again don't forget do not forget to hit
the like button and subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast you're not going
to want to miss a single episode as we
air live every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter twitch and
Facebook
simoncasting to Facebook
you can follow us on all those places
we we have a we have a cool thing we're
doing over on patreon and I've released
it publicly when we're going to continue
to release the workshops publicly we're
doing kind of like democracy workshops
over on patreon we're developing uh some
workshops the first one we did on
fivecalls.org where it's a website to
make it very easy for you to call your
representatives whether they be your
local Representatives
or your federal Representatives
and you can go to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube just [__] hit
subscribe and then go over to the
playlist section the round table of
democracy is there now what the round
table of democracy is is I always say I
always tell you engage in your democracy
engage in your democracy engage I mean
my audience can tell you I pound it into
their brains
but I never gave them the tools to
engage in the Democracy so that's what
we're doing together as a collective
over on patreon today we're going to do
a a another website uh surfing venture
over on patreon.com for the round table
of democracy so if you want to join in
if you want to join the crowd live go to
patreon.com D Tony Michaels you can join
in live but if you if you can't afford
patreon don't fret
don't if you can't join patreon don't
worry I'm going to release the workshops
publicly so you will get to see our work
that we're doing at the round table of
democracy next week next week I have an
announcement next week we have Jess
Piper
she's gonna come on the show and then
we're gonna do a round table
the round table is going to be about
engaging with your elective
Representatives on education
specifically
so this is what the round table is we
really narrow it down
to what tool we're giving you
to engage in your democracy I think this
is so important and the reason why is so
many people are overwhelmed about what
they can do to help our democracy
to be a steward in our democracy
and if we have these pointed very
specific workshops I believe you will
find one of these tools that your talent
can afford to do
some people would like to make phone
calls we're going to have more workshops
on calling your representatives some
people want to do emails we're
definitely going to do workshops on how
to email
texting campaigns
registering voters
getting out and knocking doors I I
postulated yesterday with Rachel
bittickoffer I think this would be a
great workshop on the round table of
democracy
if we collectively said okay how do we
pick out the races that are most
important to our democracy how do we
important to pay attention to that will
have the largest effect
on us electing people who are serious
about governing and serious about our
democracy so I think we should do a a
round table workshop on that so go to
patreon.com Michaels this afternoon when
I get off the air we'll do what we're
going to do another surfing of the
website I'm going to show you give you a
little tour
and you guys can see exactly what we can
you can ask questions we'll talk to each
other
in the patreon and then tomorrow morning
I will release that video to the public
don't worry
but if you want to participate live go
to patreon.com the Tony Michaels but if
you just wanna if you just want to
consume and watch the content and watch
the workshops go to the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube right now hit
subscribe you'll find all those videos
all those workshops on the playlist
Round Table of democracy just go to the
playlist Tab and you'll find it there
we're doing so much good work you as the
audience are doing such smart work at
the round table of democracy to help
save it
hello from scumbags like Trump oh my god
did you see this statement I gotta show
you this
holy moly guys on some good drugs I mean
these are really good drugs I don't know
what he's taken but I want some of it
holy [__] you gotta see this look at
this look at this this is his statement
12 hours ago
on fraud social this guy's lost his
goddamn mind
I mean he puts out a lot of lunacy over
there right I mean it's just crazy post
after crazy post after crazy post
uh Amanda says Adderall shortage I think
it's the opposite actually oh you're
saying there's a shortage because he
takes so much is that what you're saying
I think that might be what you're saying
Amanda
ow well there's no shortage at
Bedminster right now
of Adderall for sure this guy is out of
his [__] mind
here's what Grandpa post on fraud social
I'll read it the latest fake quote case
holy [__] fake case I'm gonna tell you
why he's calling these fake by the way
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
the reason why they are taking the
strategy of calling these fake you think
it's because of the fake news and he
just calls everything fake but there's a
strategy behind it but he goes on to say
brought brought by crooked Joe Biden he
well I thought it was crooked Hillary
I'm not wasn't he sleepy
I thought he was sleepy why did he
change his nickname huh
Grandpa changed Joe Biden's nickname to
Crooked instead of sleepy is it because
he finally found out that Joe Biden's
awake is that is that he's like he's
woke so maybe he's awake so maybe he's
not sleepy maybe he's just maybe I
should just use the nickname that worked
with Hillary he's such a [__] idiot
he goes on to say and derange Jack Smith
you talk about pure [__] projection
deranged Jack Smith are you kidding me
okay okay Grandpa great story
Jack Smith will hopefully be moved
into an impartial venue such as the
politically unbiased nearby state of
West Virginia this is the stupid idea
that he's gonna go to Trump country to
have this trial listen honestly again if
you wanted to be tried in the state of
West Virginia you should have went and
committed federal crimes there Grandpa
that's what you should have done then
you'd be tried in West Virginia just
like you're going to be tried in in
South Florida for your [__] crimes on
the documents in the documents case and
obstructing there just like you're going
to be tried in Fulton County Georgia and
Manhattan and Manhattan
he goes on to rant impossible
to get a fair trial in Washington D.C
which is over 95 percent anti-trump
again you shouldn't have committed crime
in such an anti-trump area then
he goes on and for which I have called
for a federal takeover
in order to bring our Capital back to
Greatness
he wants the federal capital the capital
of the United States which is controlled
by the federal government
in almost every form and fashion like
even the city council is controlled by
the federal government
he wants a federal takeover what the
[__]
I I I can't even tell you how stupid
this is
I don't know if he's he's calling for
another coup but what what who is he
calling on the Deep state to have a coup
I don't know it's definitely not the
gravy seals this time the gravy seals
aren't going to show up to save him
there's like two Trump Flags in
Washington DC today two of them
they're not gonna save him they tried it
once and thousands of them got charges
thousands
receive charges hundreds of them went to
print together
for this buffoon
I don't know what to tell you
but the the United States capital
Washington sea is already controlled by
the federal okay
he goes on to say it's now it's now a
high crime embarrassment to our nation
and indeed the world this indictment is
all about election interference now I
want to back up to the beginning
of his statement because we keep hearing
this and I keep hearing this on the
right not just from Donald Trump but
from everyone that these are fake
indictments
fake indictments
okay so I want to tell you about what
his strategy is here and what he's
trying to do
and what he knows is going to happen
Okay he knows he's going to be arrested
arrested several times here's what I
mean
he knows that the American people aren't
going to give a [__] about all the
details they're not listen not just his
supporters but American in general is
disconnected from what is important
about our government and what is
important about our Civics and what is
important about our political State they
just are they're just disconnected I
don't know what to tell you I some of
them are stupid some of them aren't some
of them just have they got three [__]
jobs they got four kids to take care of
they got dinners breakfasts to make and
paid for they got they got soccer
practice they got all kinds of [__] at
school they got homework they got all
kinds of [__] to deal with
they may not have the bandwidth to
[__] follow every single every single
detail behind this [__] buffoon's
coup attempt
or his buffoonery if you want to know
the honest truth most Americans don't
give a [__] about this guy they don't
give a [__] about Donald Trump they just
don't
he knows that
and he's going to try to use it to his
Advantage this is why I keep telling you
that it's so dangerous for people who
are legal analysts
are political commentators
to get on TV and say [__] like oh yeah
it's definitely gonna go to trial oh
it's a speedy trial oh we'll definitely
get Donald Trump in prison before he's
elected president of the United States
here's what he's counting on he's
counting on being arraigned
a lot
he's counting on being arrested
think about that for a second
think about it just just let that seep
in for a minute how many times the
headline will be Trump arrested
this will be the third today the third
time Trump has been arrested now think
about average working Americans out
there when they're arrested
especially for something as egregious as
espionage
are trying to overturn the government
think about it for a second
they arrested Stuart Rhodes and Enrique
tario and they still are not letting
them loose and not going to let them
lose for years
think about reality winner
she had one document they arrested her
immediately
she's still not she still doesn't have
her ankle bracelet off I don't believe
think about average working Americans if
they really did get into the serious
trouble that Donald Trump is in here
they would be arrested and they would be
held until they carry out their sentence
if found guilty
and we're gonna go through this this
charade of Donald Trump being quote
arrested because again it's about what
the American people hear not what about
is the truth
and the details
so think about going into next summer
when Donald Trump becomes the nominee
and he's been arrested dozens of times
that's what people think
why is he the nominee why is he out
walking around
and he's gonna say listen to me when I
tell you this he's going to say because
it's all fake it's not real
I'm not really being indicted
I'm not really going to face criminal
trial
this is all fake it's all fake headlines
it's all fake news it's all fake
indictments it's all fake cases
it's all made up so you so they and they
won't they don't want you to vote for me
that is why we have to stay vigilant
that is why these Talking Heads need to
stop saying this [__] on TV
I'm telling you I'm telling you about
the [__] politics I'm telling you
about the feelings out there in the
country I missed it in 2016 folks I
missed it I missed the Mark I didn't
think there was a snowball chance in
[__] hell for Donald Trump to win in
2016. and I missed it and I'm not gonna
miss it this time
we didn't miss it in 2020 and 2022 we
let them [__] have it we let the
world and the country know exactly how
we feel in this country we don't want
this [__]
but I'm telling you there will be there
is self-suppression at foot if we do not
stay vigilant
his message will be will resonate
if it continues this country believes
that he's been arrested time and time
again
and his and he is out and walking about
yeah I know I would love I would love
for them to detain him nothing could
please me more than today this judge
saying nope I'm not letting you out
you're gonna sit in a [__] cell
nothing would please me more but there's
something else I know
there's something else I know Maga keeps
losing their minds about a two-tier
justice system in this country and it is
a thing
if there's not more proof of a two-tier
justice system that you need in this
country
it is these cases that Donald Trump is
going to be arraigned arrested and
indicted on
anyone else would sit in a jail cell
until they're until their trial
not Donald Trump because he gets a
privileged tier of justice as he always
has his entire [__] pathetic adult
life
the reason why Manga is mad and they're
mad at the two-tier justice system is
because it isn't is no longer affording
him the amount of privilege that they
wanted to
but it is still granting him privilege
nonetheless
so here is your evidence
and I'm giving you why I say what I say
so you can be pissed off at me all you
want if I'm attacking other commentators
anti-trump commentators they're playing
into his hands I can see it clearly
I didn't see it in 2016. I made that
mistake I will never ever
make that mistake again
and it is clear his strategy here
he is going to continue to be indicted
he's going to continue to be arraigned
and arrested and that will be what
America knows only the headline think
about it only the headline Trump
arrested which is good that's good if we
the people politicize it correctly
but if he captures the messaging
and he pumps this idea into people's
heads that well [__] if they've arrested
me so many times if it's such a real
indictment why I why am I not in a jail
cell
why am I not actually arrested
bet on him taking advantage of these
facts
so you must take advantage of those
facts as well and not let down your
guard
so so when you're listening to these
analysts and people are typing their
names in the chat and I know you're mad
at me I know you're mad at me for saying
this stuff
foreign
because I'm not a lawyer and I wasn't a
United States prosecutor
I'm telling you what the politics are
I'm telling you what average Americans
are going to see and going to believe
and what he knows they're going to
believe and his strategy
I'm telling you it right now
and we must strategize to counter now
now is the time to counter we cannot go
down the dangerous road of counting on
Jack Smith saving our democracy it is up
to us
even if he's sitting in a jail cell
even if he's had a trial and been
convicted
and is seeking Appeals
he will still be able to run for
president of the United States
Bet On It
don't count on being saved
engage in your democracy like your
democracy's life depends on it
don't count on someone else to do it for
you
you have the power of the ballot
you have the power to engage you have
the power of the national narrative and
messaging against this buffoon
you can we've done it we've done it
before we will do it again
but we cannot we cannot let down our
guard and we cannot we cannot spread
misinformation of facts that are not
true today
we have to live on the truth not on
hypotheticals not on what we want to
have happen not on what we wish to have
happen
but what is true today
we must be vigilant we must defend our
democracy with our voices and I will do
it every time I don't care who you think
I'm going after I don't give a [__]
I don't care Oh Tony you're attacking
our side as if I care if I attack our
side if they're doing something then I
think is not at the heart
of saving our democracy but only to
advance Their audience and tell Their
audience what they want to hear to make
them feel good because you know I
you know that isn't my mission my
mission is not to make you feel good
about what your bias is
I know what your bias is I know how to
make you feel good I can sit here and
say oh yeah listen audience it's gonna
be oh it's gonna be great and Donald
Trump's gonna go to trial he's going to
be convicted and as soon as he's
convicted of these charges he's going to
be found at the 14th and he'll never be
able to run in the history of ever he'll
never run ever ever again and he'll just
go away and we'll lock him in a prison
cell and he'll never be able to talk
ever again
and it'll save our democracy and Jack
Smith will be the hero I could say that
to you that'd make you feel good right
that'd make you feel good I could do
feel good content I could do that I
could spread misinformation I could I
could I could make up hypotheticals that
would make the audience feel warm and
fuzzy
and say you know what you're right Tony
God damn you're right I'll just sit on
the couch and let Jack Smith say
democracy I'll just sit back and my lazy
boy and
watch the old TV and watch the legal
analysis tell me why Jack Smith is going
to save our democracy
I could do that I don't
don't let them convince you
that you are the one that you the We the
People
are the ones that stand in Donald
Trump's way he keeps saying oh yeah
they're coming after you I just stand in
their way he'd understand it's the other
way around
just like they're like oh if if they can
do that to him then they can do that
that guy they should if they can do it
to you they should be able to do it to
him you [__] idiots
we are the one that stands in his way
he's not standing in the way of anyone
we are standing in his way
don't count on a jury
don't count on the doj don't count on
Jack Smith
politicize the issue make politics let's
win this [__] election
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
use every single one of his words every
single one of his criminal Acts
every single one of his lunatic and
deranged statements every single one of
those hostage videos that he makes
we're gonna use every [__] one of
them to win this election every [__]
one of them
there will not be one issue not one
issue not one statement not one clip
that I will not politicize on this show
you can Garen damn T that
but we must do it together
we must do it together and in one voice
tell Donald Trump we don't give a [__]
what jury rather it's in DC in Georgia
in Manhattan in Florida or in West
Virginia what a dumb [__]
oh what a stupid idea
I don't care where the juries are
we are his [__] jury you are his
[__] jury it is you
and you have the power of the ballot you
are the juror they can't they can't tell
you you can't be a juror
you'll get to go to the box and you'll
get to Mark no on Donald Trump
that's what you will get to do with your
ballot
so stay vigilant stay vigilant and I'm
Gonna Keep pounding this drum as long as
the media keeps rolling out these people
who keep saying this crazy [__] this
dangerous [__] I'm gonna do it speaking
of dangerous [__] did you see a bill
Barr on CNN ah what a [__] weak ass
[__] ass [__] Bill Barr is
just now saying this [__] and then Mike
Pence which one should I do first Mike
Pence or the or
should I eat my pants or should I do uh
Bill Barr first it's almost the same
it's almost the exact same Mike Pence
has come up with the script now
of how he did not participate in the
coup I was not part of the coup attempt
it was all him
you notice that energy that Mike Mike
Pence has now he's like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I never
wanted to commit a coup I never even
considered doing a coup why did you call
Dan quell then why did you call him and
say come on
Nan I can do this right
why did you seek seek your counsel to
find any way possible to overturn the
election Mike Pence we know that from
the January 6 elect earrings they were
looking for any any way they could to
[__] appease
Grandpa Poopypants they were looking for
any Avenue they could take for Mike
Pence to overthrow the election without
him without him being in danger of
facing a federal prison sentence and
they determined
in in what facts were laid before them
which they should have known this
without even having to do all this
research and try to seek out anyway Mike
Pence could wiggle his way into giving
the election to Donald Trump like Donald
Trump wanted
all they had to do is just use their
brains and know that you can't do that
the pr the vice president United States
does not have the power the unilateral
power to hand over an election everyone
knows that we've known that from the
first time that they floated this idea
out in the public even in private when
people found out that they were floating
the idea that Mike Pence is just gonna
Crown Donald Trump present in the United
States and king of our democracy what
the [__] are you talking about and [__]
on the Constitution the [__] out of here
with that nonsense
that's a dumb get get a better [__]
plan come on it's not even close to
being a good plan to overthrow our
democracy doesn't make any sense if it
made sense listen to me if it made sense
Joe Biden the vice president United
States under Obama could have just said
Hillary Clinton's the president [__] it
[__] Donald Trump Hillary Clinton's a
president dropped the gavel bam
we would have averted a national crisis
in Donald Trump being our President our
commander-in-chief and putting us in
danger every [__] day our national
security and like
and continue to have that [__]
buffoon in as a charge of our federal
government he doesn't even know he
didn't even he was President for four
goddamn years and he doesn't even know
that DC is under Federal control what a
[__] idiot
technically technically the Democrats
are wanting to get DC out of federal
control and make it a state
give it its own sovereignty for away
from the federal government what a
[__] idiot
these people just don't have brain cells
to rub together including Mike Pence
and really honestly he thinks we don't
have brain cells to rub together when he
says [__] like this in front of a camera
here's his new scripted defense
on why he chose the Constitution over
Donald Trump you're full of [__] Mike
you are so full of [__] [__]
I want the American people to know that
I had no right to overturn the election
and then on that day president Trump
asked me to put him over the
Constitution but I chose the
Constitution he wants to let the
American people know that he did not
have the right to overthrow the yeah we
know that
no [__] Sherlock
thanks thanks now Mike thanks now oh man
two and a half years later thank God you
said it now you [__] coward
what a weak piece of [__] now that he is
part of the testimony against Donald
Trump in trying to commit a Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup because it's likely it's
likely that Mike Pence still has a
little bit of legal liability here in
the coup attempt in their attempt to
continue to look for a way to appease
Donald Trump's effort to overthrow our
government
so yeah Mike Pence's cooperation is
important to this case against Donald
Trump but also to make sure Mike Pence
doesn't see the inside of a [__]
prison cell
come on
of course Mike Pence is gonna say
whatever the [__] he has to say to make
sure that he his testimony not only
buries Donald Trump but saves his ass
what do you think all the [__] was
for the last two and a half years when
he's like well I'm uh the president
really um he he he he he uh blah blah
blah yakety schmackity
and now now Bill Barr and Mike Pence now
have worked up the courage and the and
the nuts in their sack to say what they
should have said in December of 2020
when they knew what Donald Trump was
doing they knew he was trying to subvert
democracy they knew he was trying to
overthrow our government listen you want
to see some strength Mark milley went in
front of cameras twice twice to tell
active and inactive and Veterans of the
military hey you took an oath to a
document not a guy make sure you stick
to that oath he said it twice in front
of a microphone we didn't hear a [__]
peep not a [__] peep
from Mike Pence nor Bill Barr in
December 2020 or the first week in in
January of 2021.
I'll show you the bill Barr clip here
later the important thing is is that
we're at the top of the hour we have
tons of sparklers in the chat
and I'm so glad to have Hal Sparks on
the show finally finally made it to the
show I'm re I'm very happy to have him
here so what we're going to do we're
gonna take a quick break when we come
back
Hal Sparks is going to join us don't go
anywhere
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show we have
Hal Sparks with us waiting in the Green
Room listen if you want your pardon
blanket they're [__] real now I know
forever it's been parody and satire but
you can actually get a pardon blanket
just go to store
dot I am Gabe sanchez.com let's go to
store dot I am Gabe sanchez.com you will
find the pardon blankets on his merch
store or go to the Tony michaels.com go
to the Tony michaels.com you'll find
Gabe's merch store link right there on
the Tony michaels.com that's right the
pardon blankets are real I don't know
how many you want to order and send to
Washington I'm not really sure they're
probably going to need a few pardons or
maybe just the idea of a pardon what do
you think houseworks do you think
they're you think Joe Budden you think
Joe Biden's gonna be handing out pardons
anytime soon no actually I think uh he's
even family members are like definitely
not getting a pardon from this guy I I
guess I'm gonna have to ride it out
because the oh my God it would interfere
with the brand you know the interesting
thing was and this is uh yeah I'm sure
you've seen this all over Fox and the
like is that since they couldn't nail
down that Biden talked about business on
any of these phone calls right we have
the transcript this morning right yes uh
is that you know in general he was just
like hey good morning how you doing oh
it's fun it's all right okay it's you
know he said hello and that kind of
stuff right the reason the reason
they've been talking about the whole
thing he was selling the brand well what
was the Biden brand ultimately
competency of family Catholicism right
trustworthiness and so when you're a
dude who's up to is uh you know nether
regions in in hookers and crack at a
certain point people are like I'm not
sure if I should trust you what you
might do is go no no I'm still my dad's
kid right I'm trying to live up to my
dad's symbol here he is well and yeah
that's right well even his brother even
his brother uh was part of that Biden
brand right Beau Biden was part of that
Biden brand Beau Biden was going to be
you know before he got cancer and passed
away he was going to be the next Joe
Biden right that Hunter was never going
to be the next Joe Biden it was always
going to be bo that lived on in the
Legacy I mean you know and this is this
is the craziest part is when I read this
transcript this morning Devin Archer
even at the end of it when he's like
well the only thing I can really tell
you in my opinion about barisma is that
marisma would have went out of business
if they wouldn't have gotten Hunter
Biden and I'm like what other reason
would berezma have then to go hey can
you consult with us or we'll go out of
business like we don't exist like Jesus
Christ well again I I use this kind of
this test all the time and I'm I've yet
to see anybody crested on somebody who
actually makes this stupid argument
about barisma's uh you know corrupt past
or whatever is that if you have a gun to
your head and you have to invest every
dime you have your children's college
fund ever your IRA your retirement fund
everything and you've got you it's a
binary choice you can invest it before
Hunter Biden is at barisma or after
which one do you do I don't want to hear
any of the criminal conspiracies right
right daughtering old man who's also and
you know an alpha male criminal
conspirator Master Mastermind Mastermind
by the way yeah that's right I want to
hear you you've got a you got a coin to
flip and you hope it lands on one side
which side is it well barisma is
currently a functioning company that
makes a profit for its investors before
Hunter Biden showed up that wasn't true
as a matter of fact the primary thing
that happened your money if you invested
in barisma and this is why they were
paying uh zlicheski was paying shoken to
have an investigation kind of he was
like basically shulkin was extorting him
I'll have this investigation open you
pay me uh you know I'll you scam money
to me and I will not follow through on
the investigation it'll just sit there
but the minute you stop paying me that
folder on you Finds Its way to
somebody's desk that's what shokun's
business model was and the and that's
why the IMF and everybody else wanted
him gone they wanted somebody that every
folder Finds Its way to a desk and
shoken was paying to make sure it never
did and that's what allegedly the phone
call was supposedly about
which didn't turn out that way
apparently Hunter was not on the team he
didn't he didn't know that that was the
whole thing he's like well well hey easy
I I tell this to Gabe Sanchez easy on
the facts Hal you're really gonna you're
really gonna get confused that's too
fast right you're really gonna confuse
and [__] up manga here okay and see I I
don't I don't get rid of the manga
listeners here we still have a lot of
Maga listeners here because I have
people that love me and people who love
to hate me that come here and watch the
show and I actually sometimes I have
more love for the people who love to
hate me than the people who love me nah
that's your own psychological damage
we've talked about that at length right
exactly exactly I am I am kind of a
little loose in the you know screws here
yeah well that you need to just to deal
with these topics sometimes because I I
honestly gotta I think a certain level
of insanity is necessary to even be able
to comprehend the argument from the
other side and try to shape it into
something because I find myself and I'm
sure you do too trying to go like what
what are they actually trying to say is
happening here because it's obviously
not and any sane person looking at this
knows that's not true so what are they
trying to make if I was one of their
followers right what are they actually
trying to make me believe because I'm
not even sure that's true except be a
Biden crime family you know what I mean
like at one point like if everything's a
hashtag then all bets are off nothing
has to make sense but at a certain point
what what what well this could be the
world of social media that we live in
that's doing this here's an example
here's an example yesterday I Rachel
bidikoff are on and she's like you know
I really like the politics of this whole
thing where they're saying oh he has the
freedom to lie why can't Donald Trump
lie about the election and it's like is
that really the argument that you want
to make because that's really what
they're saying at the heart of well it's
his freedom of speech he gets to say
whatever he wants even if it's not true
he gets to say whatever he wants right
that's their argument at this point it's
like why are you using the argument that
he has the right to lie and that that
you you believing the lie you know what
I mean
trying to unwind these things is crazy
oh I did a clip of Glenn Beck yesterday
yeah on the on the show because I
sometimes when you want the dumbest take
on things and and Dan bongolio doesn't
do short videos anymore because he's he
was he got tired of me like herb
stomping them he literally does doesn't
release clips anymore because he's
scared but Glenn's still dumb enough to
do it so but it's the same argument and
that's yesterday he made that exact
argument argument you're talking about
which is this idea that oh what are we
going to do Outlaw lying now then 99 of
99 of all politicians will just go to
jail like okay first of all how do you
vote because if you're saying 99 of 99
whatever that mathematic mess is is
untrustworthy then what have you been
selling me this 50 50 binary between two
parties for a long time anyways
obviously this has been a sales pitch I
don't buy anything that comes out of you
because you're just this just this is
like low res 90s nihilism as a political
strategy like what does it I mean
nothing really matters you know
um right that's it because the world's
[__] anyways the world anyway so let's
just smash it into the whole way right
then why are you even convincing anybody
to vote for anybody at that point
exactly bunker right now with a big can
of beans just you know way waiting for
that's what they used to do that's what
they used to do didn't work out for him
you know what I mean well he's still
he's moved into at the the well that's a
well I'll get to that in a second but he
ultimately made the case that you're
talking about where he was like
um if you if you can't lie then all
politicians are gonna hire it's like a
hacked joke from 1987 that he just kind
of still carries around and whips out
which is I mean again why trust him in
anything he ever says if that's the case
but but ultimately the problem isn't it
and it was kind of what they try to do
is extrapolate it to the audience you're
it's going to be illegal they're going
to come after you and say you're lying
and put you in jail for lying because
you won't have free space anymore and
they want to scare people like that
which is just ignorant and stupid
whatever but they're it's weird that
they don't make the distinction like
this is the president of the United
States who is instructing people to
carry out actions under the directive of
the president of the United States right
and he is lying about what other members
of the United States government have
said that are supposed to be a source
that this group is trusting so actually
the vice president and I are in total
agreement that he can flip the votes
that he said that on he they sent it out
through his uh campaign and he said it
to people in there and he made sure his
attorney the White House counsel who is
the guy who everybody wants in the room
to make sure what they're doing is above
board and going to go through if you if
it's legislation you just wanted to pass
a a scotus test so you want the White
House counsel there to give you advice
on yeah this is legal we can get this
bill this executive order through we're
not all wasting our time now that's
called government that's called
government yes it is
and in the case yeah in the case of
Donald Trump that's the last thing he
wants to do so right he's keeping this
guy out of the room because he knows
this guy will raise an objection and
that everybody else in the room will
know that that guy's not bullshitting
them because it that's his gig that's
his job that's his he cares what his
name means Trump doesn't that's what
that your two honest nonsense works you
know was about so so Trump was directing
people to carry out activities based on
lies that he was interrupting the flow
of information within the federal
government to insert so it the the
equivalent is
there is a the the
Congress gives you passes ability to an
authorize use of military force
and that's all it is and for to fight
terrorism or whatever and you're Dick
Cheney and George Bush is in a coma and
you're now the president of the United
States oh Jesus yeah right and Dick
Cheney decides in the aumf which is an
authorized use of military force against
terrorist groups to he scribbles into
the margins uh I like the Congress has
declared that the government of Iran is
a terrorist group therefore the rest of
this bill applies I will use the
authorization against them yes and he
writes it in there and says this was in
the original draft of the bill like he
creates a second page between the
opening and the signature and the
question is the question is does he use
a Sharpie that's uh you know no that's
what Trump would do actually have it
hyped up in a sense okay so it would
look real it would look real instead of
just but that that act
would be a violation of his
constitutional duties it would be
against the the separation of powers act
it would be unconstitutional and it
would be criminal if Dick Cheney did
that okay and that and the thing is I
show you that in writing because speech
and texts are not there's no difference
in the Constitution writing something or
saying something aren't right different
so if Cheney did that he would go to
jail for that [__]
Trump is going to go to jail for this
[__] and the reason he is is because he
did exactly what I said except he did it
verbally in a room and eliminated
anybody who might be the editor right of
that document out of the room and the
reason why I did it with his voice and
his in talking is because he probably
can't write very well I mean I had the
best words he has the best I know words
I have the best words he does really
truly had the best words right he does
absolutely let me tell you but uh and
you were talking a little bit about
um Pence yes and and and Bill Barr right
because those two are the ones that
really could have those two could have
stood in Trump's way of of really
perpetuating this message in December of
2020. and Mark milley tried it yeah yeah
they did to the extent that they could
there's a there's a
um there's a little bit of like
recognizing the driver is drunk and
trying to get your hands on the wheel
without triggering them emotionally so
that you can pull the car over to the
side of the road this is sad that this
this was the situation that we were in
right oh it was it was a situation
during Nixon I'm sure it was the
situation to some degree maybe during
Hoover right you know there's a couple
of areas along the way and quite frankly
it Trump like every other failure in
Trump's life it was a giant Act of loud
impotency that's it was effectively what
was going on because it was never going
to be successful this attack on the
capitol it was never going to actually
be a functional coup and part of the
reason was because he put idiots in
charge of it but also the other reason
is that he took on people that he
thought would be he thought Bill Barr
was going to be his Roy Cohn and he
believed that Mike Pence would be his
sycophantic second in charge Kim Jong-un
which he was to some degree right except
some degree the question he he didn't
understand that the question you know
when he hires he people to do that in a
business is because people do that
because their paycheck relies on his
whim and if they get fired nobody's
going to want to hire somebody who used
to work for Donald Trump because they're
a crook so they're like people like
Michael Cohen and others have you know
spend a good amount of time in in sort
of the same situation Noel Dunphy was in
with Rudy Giuliani which is this kind of
like you know get somebody on the hook
financially where they can't escape and
then just start treating them like
garbage and then make them do things
that go against their ethics or whatever
and then like pay a bill just so they
can stand on their own two feet for a
couple of days and then do it again and
again wash rinse repeat and this the
problem is is in government
people like Bill Barr and Mike Pence
have a long game for their for
themselves that go Way Beyond Donald
Trump unlike the maggots you know they
they themselves and Bill Barr the reason
people suggested Bill Barr to Donald
Trump for this guy because Donald Trump
you know wanted to be Kim Jong-un but in
a sort of parallel track
uh Bill Barr believes in the Supreme
executive power of the presidency and
that's what he was always dovetailing
things towards in in those sort of
Reagan Bush years especially under Bush
one and the idea was that he wants to
start laying legal bricks that allow the
president of the United States without
consulting Congress to declare war at
some point right that's what Bill Barr
and his ilk want to have happen they
don't like the drag of like we could
have ended this [__] with a couple of
these countries a couple of years ago if
they'd had just gotten out of our
goddamn way right right
the separation of power in a fascist way
because that's all ultimately their
personality right and Trump [__] it up
you can't you can't announce it and go
stomping in and go
um by the way I think everybody needs
new uniforms pointy shoulders gun strap
some sort of Tibetan symbol somewhere
around here maybe lightning bolt collars
looking very good you can't do that
again because everybody maybe SS on the
uniform somewhere you know well you know
you don't you know I
I have to I have to tell you that I I
have to uh bring up a beef right now
that we have between our shows because
our shows a lot of times are at the same
time and Gabe Sanchez months and months
ago brought tiny hands and there's
apparently uh you and Gabe Sanchez are
gonna have a tiny hands cage match
because apparently you have brought tiny
hands on and there's a tiny hand
controversy here that is between our
shows and and I want to get this out in
the open this is the elephant in the
room is this tiny hand controversy that
somehow someway house Sparks stole the
tiny hands idea from Gabe Sanchez I
don't know how much truth is in it but
we're really gonna have to make sure we
play this out and you know in full form
the easiest answer is I've never seen
Gabe Sanchez's tiny hands bit but I will
say that yes or the sexy liberal Comedy
Tour that you know we did the tiny hands
has been a thing yeah we did the we did
a digital version of it and I bought a
pair of those and glued the tips of the
thumb and the and the end finger
together for this this business so and I
use them on I use them on that show two
and a half years ago okay so wow
technically okay well then we're gonna
have to make sure we smoke this out and
we we make sure that this tiny hand
controversy goes away because the
audience members talk about the tiny
hand controversy all the time because we
have sparklers in the chat on my show
all the time there's okay there's this
big there's this big thing and and
by the way I have news for Gabe as well
we're not the only ones who've thought
of this over the time no right exactly
obviously but but the thing is is that I
just want to create a stir to see if we
can get a tiny hands cage match that's
all I'm going for that's that's all I'm
hoping for is a tiny hands cage match
that's all I want look that's all I'm
looking for all right Tony listen buddy
uh Abe and I are not here for your
bizarre
fetishes here you certainly um you
certainly are at least at least to some
degree this is uh yeah
neither one of us needs uh to just
placate your sexual needs in some sort
of bizarre oiled up tiny hands
monstrosity that plays out I I don't
need to be some sort of Fellini short
yeah for your physical pleasure I think
I think for sure this is going to be
clipped and played on the internet
somewhere no doubt and we will need a
tiny cage yeah tiny cage for the tiny
hands I don't know if we do it animated
or what we do but I I think we need to
have some sort of uh some sort of
conclusion here to this controversy that
happens in our chats so I'm glad you're
on the show I'm so glad you're on the
show because I I have a million
questions that I that I have to ask you
but I only got 10 more minutes so I I
want to get away from uh maybe the tiny
hand controversy that doesn't make a
shit's bits of difference in the
narrative but I want because this is the
first time you've been on the show I
want
um you to tell you on this why it's so
important uh shows like ours because I I
really truly see shows like ours as the
the independent real media because we
don't have anyone telling us what the
[__] to do there's no one standing over
us going you can't say that and you
can't say this and when someone says
something really stupid on tyt or
somewhere else in the media or even on
MSNBC or CNN me and you can stand there
and say that's a bunch of [__] and
they're and and it's only it's only our
side quote-unquote our side as if me and
you have a side but our side telling you
a bunch of [__] that isn't true and
that's not gonna happen right right and
we have that Independence so tell the
audience because I think this is
important to talk about
um and that our form of media
and in that and that we do have that
independence from what is what is the
establishment
um because I I noticed several months
ago Jank younger talking like you were
some sort of paid operative for the
Democratic establishment yeah have you
ever watched Cal in your life yeah right
yeah no uh he yeah he thinks I'm I work
for the DNC or something like that and
it's and again this has little to do
with me I will not or or even you in
that regard right those guys have a
business model and that business model
is based on like teasing denied and
speaking of fetishes it is the idea of
like if they if they ever catch if the
dog ever catches the car they're [__]
so their job is to make sure the car is
always out of range either by you know
lies manipulation or or just fabrication
of a concept and so they create things
that I fight back against which mute the
vote and all I care about is look I
don't I don't care how many [__]
Trump Flags you have on your car you
have one vote I don't care whether you
wear a Biden sticker or hat or anything
you have one vote as well you are
absolutely equal in the voting power you
have to every other human being that is
of legal age in this country and has the
it has citizenship and the right to vote
so use it and anybody who tries to talk
you out of it has another plan for your
life than you do and it's not good
they want you folded in behind them so
that they can use you as leverage go if
I tell my people not to show up you're
[__] and that will be my PowerPoint
and that unless these people are union
members who all share a job and
therefore similar needs that's messed up
that is a that is a point of
manipulation so their their you know
then you add another layer of kind of
what you were talking about is that you
know tyt's got their millionaire funding
and they've got it they've got a certain
amount of audience capture they can't go
outside of and you and I as awkward and
difficult as it might be at times don't
have even audience capture I have said
things to my audience that they didn't
want to hear at the time but turned out
to be true because I respect them more
than other people do and so they might
hear the same nine talking points and
I'll go look Joe Biden cannot sign a
piece of paper and make your student
debt go away right it happened it's not
going to happen that is a lie being told
by other people so that you are
disappointed later and you won't vote
and you'll blame the person that they
want you to blame that's right that's
what I call the stroke of a pen fallacy
they're using that against you and I'm
not going to let you believe that some
complex issue can be solved with the
stroke of the pen because if it could
the only reason not to do it is because
you're an evil son of a [__] and that's
what you're saying about someone else
and that's immoral so well and it is
authoritarian it is authoritarian at its
root too which is which is the danger
that we're in right now is that this
country ultimately for some reason left
and right seeks this idea that
authoritarianism uh is the is the answer
to all their prayers right I mean here's
here's a prime example I want to show
you this statement from Donald Trump
um and there's a lot in this [__]
right lunacy but in the very first part
he says the latest fake case brought by
crooked Joe Biden and Doreen Jack Smith
that's the thing I want to focus on here
is because I've been hearing um um legal
one how fake as in quotes right no no
well actually cases and quotes but
here's the thing here's the thing and I
see this playing out because I'll be
honest with you
I missed a lot of this stuff in 2016 and
I was wrong about Donald Trump in 2016
and I refuse to be wrong about him again
and I see what he's doing because the
American people are only going to see
the headlines of his arraignments his
arrestments and his indictments so over
and over and over again over the next
year it's going to be Trump arrested
Trump arrested again Trump arrested
again Trump arrested again Trump arrests
again and then by the time we get to the
Republican um National Convention next
summer and he has enough delegates to
win on the first ballot because that's
how it works I don't care what what you
want to say or what you want to do as
long as he has enough delegates he will
win on the first ballot that's how it
works now when he stands on stage and
he's not under rest he's not in a prison
cell he can say all these are fake
they're all fake see I told you they
were fake otherwise I wouldn't be
standing here if they weren't fake I can
already see his narrative I can already
see what he's trying to do now what is
happening in the media is some of these
legal analysis some of this legal stuff
around us like oh don't worry Jack Smith
is going to save our democracy Jack
Smith is going to go to trial it's going
to be a rocket docket it's going to be
Speedy to trial he'll definitely be
arrested he'll definitely be convicted
he'll definitely be 14th which there's
no guarantee there is no guarantee that
those things will happen it could happen
it may it is not likely when you look at
Federal cases and the timing that they
use to play out now I agree that Jack
Smith is using a strategy by keeping him
off the same indictment as the
co-conspirators to try to speed this
along but there's no guarantee of that
and I believe that the federal judge
that is in this case she's going to act
as a federal judge not as someone trying
to save the country not as someone
trying to rig it against Donald Trump
she is going to be a fair federal judge
in this case and that's going to be
that's going to be the at the detriment
of the media's talking point that
somehow someway Donald Trump will be
arrested and not be able to run for
president of the United States next year
well here's the thing okay in our
country you can run for president from a
prison cell so again matter that that
part isn't part the the question is will
and and will be about whether you're
willing to vote for him or not and there
is an increasing part of this and like
this goes back to what I was talking
about with Bill Barr and Mike Pence Bill
Barn Mike Pence are still shooting for
that Supreme executive power aspect of
of the presidency but they have to do it
by a slow trickle or the people will not
go for it that it has to happen in fits
and starts and little little steps
forward through legal cases and scotus
hearings and [__] like that and they had
a plan for that that was probably 30
years long but they were working on it
and Donald Trump said it back
15 years minimum that's why they're
turning on him not because they're you
know outraged by his morality but
because he he says it out in the open
and he's going to screw the pooch and so
many legal limits are being put on him
even by
what is effectively a sycophantic house
Republican party they're still not
allowing for this you know because they
have this huge fear of of Joe Biden
winning again they're not allowing these
steps to go forward the way they needed
to go so that that's the big fear that's
happening and that's why those guys are
turning on him and right now what you
have is you have Donald John Trump who
was president of the United States for
four years still running as an outsider
and you have you right now and and put
aside this idea of like whether people
like or don't like uh Biden and poles
and yada yada because look at what
happened to George W bush nobody
switched horses Midstream during Iraq
war economically we're in the same
situation same with infrastructure it's
that's less of the issue but Donald John
Trump is in a situation where he needs
to win the nomination slash the
presidency to save himself so that he's
on a scorched Earth policy about this
and anybody who isn't all in he has to
go all against and that will
increasingly divide this party in half
into never trumpers and ever trumpers
and that's where they are there and
Donald Trump who was already president
who has already got a record to run on
as president what he would do to his own
party still barely has 50 percent
that's insane because he's got to win a
nomination again this is not this is
much closer to the Nixon circumstance
if Nixon had already been had resigned
for breaking the law like this is you
know because Nixon lost and then ran
again and lost her you know and then won
and so this situation you've got half of
these people who are not interested in
voting for Donald Trump like they're
angry about it and grossed out by it and
they are Evangelical Christians who are
waking up to the fact that they were
like well he got the Roe v Wade thing
done so everything else about them I
don't need him anymore that's yeah
that's his biggest problem like he wants
credit right now but it's not he can't
promise to change the law the law has
already changed he's and he won't stop
uh you know Congress from passing law
and he's not going to veto a
codification he doesn't know what any of
those things mean he doesn't know how to
do it right and none of the people
around him would they'd hand him a piece
of paper and he'd go ah look what I did
I made a poo-poo does it have my name on
it that's right he just he just wants to
sign everything like it's an autograph
right and the other half of that is for
him
half of that group will jump to whoever
else becomes the second choice
the other half of his group will attack
that person like a pack of rabid
Wolverines with a nut sack fetish and
they will just
so are you saying they're going to eat
Rhonda Santos's meatballs is that what
you're saying okay that's what you were
saying I wanted to they're not going to
eat them they're gonna gnaw on them oh
okay okay not fully eaten they don't
want to give them
just destroy them not eat that just you
know like when they drag them around by
them
that's what they're doing now
technically I mean that's what we're
seeing play out that you know from you
know Chris Christie and a couple of
those other people are the shots across
the bow that allow other people to step
in there and and then there are the
second tier people who are like the
archers in this that are like no I
totally support the front line but I'm
firing over the top right and and that's
you know Vivek ramaswamy and some of
these are like a totally support Trump
and what he's doing but if it were me I
would uh right that you couldn't even
say that previous to you know last year
ultimately there it does not matter
because there is a huge chunk of
Republicans that our Old School Big R on
their jerseys who will vote for house
members and vote for Senate members and
pull a like what progressives did to
Hillary Clinton these people will do to
Donald Trump if he's the nominee because
it's a bridge too far for them right
it's it and there and and and it's not
because they're suddenly Honorable in
that regard it's not because they've
suddenly woken up it's because he has
outlived his usefulness the return on
investment is not worth it they have
crunched the numbers and all it ever
comes up to is whatever your plan is
Donald Trump will [__] it up and he
can't win he's a loser he's a loser he's
going to lose and if he's on the ticket
that group of people
half of them will vote for House and
Senate they'll show up but they'll just
leave president blank and the other half
of that group will not show up at all
and you stack that with all the maggots
that won't be on if he's not on the
ticket or if he has to pick somebody
who's second tier if they if the RNC
talks him into taking on DeSantis or
somebody like that as his second they're
not they're going to bail on that as
well because he's been he's being
controlled by the globalists whatever
that storyline they tell themselves will
be that's it well I can't I can't wait
for the Republican primary it's going to
be a hell of a fight speaking of fights
I gotta address a couple things in chat
before I let you go I'm so glad you came
on the show sure you got to come back
first of all some people in the chat
thought I voted for Donald Trump what
are you crazy I didn't vote for Donald
Trump or joining I've never voted for a
republican in my [__] life okay you
can mark that down number two speaking
of fights the chat says to a tiny hands
cage match let's get ready to thumble
so I I don't know I think we should I
really think we should pretend that this
is a real controversy and we should play
this out and we should have a tiny hands
cage I I have to say I agree I don't
know I think it should happen no I I
know really like that's that's Tony's Mo
everybody he's always looking for a
controversy because I'm always looking
for something that's the most trumpy
thing about him exactly what about Tony
he thinks he's always looking for us
that's right yep there is wrong they're
not wrong there's no bad breaths it's
only some bad press I would argue that
the press that came out about dershowitz
and his massages at Epstein's but that
was that got his name in the papers
that's true well did you see the latest
read Giuliani thing he had an obsession
with his assistant's tits or something
yes right yeah yeah I can't I can't even
I don't even know that I can play it on
YouTube I'll get banned that's how I
read it out loud it's disgusting and
here's the thing I I wouldn't talk like
that way to a woman anyways but if I did
I would at least I would in theory
it would have to be a situation where I
was
at least attractive in the conventional
sense to a degree where she knew I was
messing around and I wasn't talking to
her like someone who had purchased her
in you know on a on in Romania from uh
one of the Tate brothers
well that is really giuliani's Mo we've
seen it on Borat 2 when he was tucking
in his shirt below his balls
that girl was 15 years old and he
believed he believed he was going to do
something in that bedroom and he wasn't
talking in his shirt he was moving his
boner around is what he was doing that's
what I don't I don't know if dudes out
there know this but when you get a a a
stiff one you got to kind of adjust it
sometimes and I think that he was not
tucking in his shirt he was tucking in
something else but you know yeah no I
think he was about manipulating it so
that he could get her to touch him and
you know reach in there and get that hey
what'd you grab that's it's [__] bro
he's [__] gross and he believed her
to be underage and in that in the in the
transcripts that came out where he's
talking about what's her name Noelle
Dunphy in terms of she's my my daughter
my little girl or whatever when he's
using that kind of language
he should stop broadcasting he should
stop talking but Rudy Giuliani and
Donald Trump never disappoint they are
always going to make it worse for
themselves yeah
yeah they're the king of the keep
digging crowd
disappointing America's mayor or some
[__] it's really weird well that's gone
yeah well I was going to say
that that'll be in quotes from now on oh
boy here comes America's mayor
um yeah no one's going to be one and
known as a mayor at all after Rudy
Giuliani like they just don't want to be
known as America well that'll be the
like that'll that'll be now the slang
for some like skeevy dude right here I
walk into the bathroom this dude's
wagging it around like he's America's
mayor
oh my God house Sparks how sparks you
never disappoint thank you my friend
come back anytime come and join us for
next time but I've got I got family
stuff to take care of so uh take care of
yourself and take care of your view
sounds great everyone house Sparks
everyone stick around we'll be right
back
right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
thank you foreign
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
everybody
now [__] Sparks
never disappoints
thank you Hal for joining the show
[Music]
thanks to the audience for um working Us
in line to get calendar on the show
maybe I'll go on his show when I'm not
live here he does his evening shows
um so maybe I'll go on one of his
evening shows one of these times
um to go talk to the sparklers over
there and you can go join his show you
should definitely go follow Hal on
YouTube you should catch his show when
you can when it's not competing with I'm
just kidding
we got a lot of sparklers in the chat we
love having the sparklers here they are
they are honorary members of the [__] em
fam and so I know the [__] fam are
welcome over in the sparklers chat so
you should go check out Hal's show go to
halsparks.com the talisparks.com you can
find all that or you can just follow him
almost anywhere at Hal Sparks Instagram
Twitter uh Facebook threads anywhere
anywhere anywhere you got the socials
and you can follow Hal Sparks or go to
houseparks.com you'll find all the links
all the linkies there so thanks Hal for
for joining us on the show I want to
show you this clip
I have uh Bill and Bill Barr
Hal mentioned that the tiny cage match
was somehow this sexual fetish that I
need to have what does that even matter
if that's what it is that's what it is I
still want doesn't don't you want to see
the tiny hands cage match to some degree
I want to see this play out to some
degree what is what is this tiny hands
cage match that we have I'm telling you
I'm telling you this would be a great
piece of content we cannot let this
controversy falter we cannot let it go
on
with with no attention we have to give
this controversy attention so please
I I implore you to make sure to continue
the tiny hands Cheeto chop controversy
that's what we should call it the Cheeto
chop conspiracy the Cheeto job
conspiracy with the guy with the last
name Sanchez
oh boy oh boy oh boy you guys are
probably missing Gabe Sanchez today huh
he's still out he's still out
he's still out
he'll be out tomorrow too we're gonna
have Boston Brian Boston Brian gonna do
bonehead of the week with us I gotta
admit to you
I'm not exactly sure how I'm gonna do
the graphics and stuff for bonehead of
the week I'm gonna try my best what I'm
gonna really try to do honestly is I'm
gonna try to choose people that we've
had on before
so I don't have to do the graphics I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna [__] you uh
yeah listen the reason why Gabe Sanchez
is an integral part of the show is a lot
of times
this show would not look the way it
looks without his graphic artist Bree
his graphic artistry
this the last two days I've done the
thumbnail though I will admit that I did
the thumbnail but hey you know that's
not too difficult to write out the words
and get a good picture but I I will tell
you that sometimes um Gabe Sanchez
finds the perfect freeze frame of a face
for the for the thumbnail to tell the
perfect story right I'm not quite that
good just not that good but tomorrow for
bonehead of the week we'll have Boston
Brian on
so if you're excited about um having
Boston Brian on to do bonehead of the
week because Gabe Sanchez is out go
ahead and right now hit the Subscribe
button on YouTube don't forget to hit
subscribe you're not going to want to
miss it
you can also watch tomorrow bonehead the
week on Facebook at the Tony Michaels
you can also watch us on Twitch follow
us it's free over there twitch.tv Tony
Michaels if you want commercial free
watching on Twitch
and you want to support the show you can
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account we've had a few new
subscribers here today thank you very
much and don't forget to re-subscribe
every month so we get that couple extra
bucks that you get and you get
commercial free viewing on Twitch it's
free you just link your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account you get
one free subscription on Twitch with
Amazon gaming
and all the directions are at the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can find the directions
on how to link those two there
also don't forget to go check out the
patreon we're going to do a we're going
to do a short one but it's going to be a
round table of democracy today after the
show later on this afternoon we'll do a
Roundtable democracy so all the patreon
members out there don't forget this
afternoon I'll I'll announce it on
patreon and put it on patreon the link
and what we're going to talk about over
there it won't be very long we're just
gonna do like a a walk around of a
website so you guys can see exactly how
to find information
and how to find those particular tools
that you're looking for when you're
engaging in your democracy that's what
the round table of democracy is about is
to provide you the tools to engage in
your democracy and I want to thank all
the new listeners here today we've got a
ton of new people here in the chat you
have a ton of new people you're welcome
here to join the [__] fam rather you
love me or you love to hate me you're
welcome here to listen and to engage in
your democracy here on the Tony Michaels
podcast as well you can go to
patreon.com to participate and engage
there but don't fret if you can't be a
patreon member don't worry we will
provide all the workshops for for free
that's right for free
you just join you just subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube you go
to the community or excuse me yeah no
the playlist tab excuse me I'm getting
lost go to the playlist tab
and find the playlist
Roundtable of democracies all the
workshops will be there free for you to
view after we develop them on patreon so
we we do the work on patreon and then we
present it to you to the public so you
can use those tools as well and use
those workshops speaking of Workshop
Bill Barr really should have workshopped
um
what his narrative was all this time
he's finally gotten to the point to
where he's like oh yeah that's right
that's right now I remember Donald Trump
was trying to commit a coup and I should
have stopped him maybe I should have
said something back then maybe I
shouldn't have waited two and a half
years to say something hmm
it's kind of funny he was on CNN this
morning
with Caitlin Collins here's a little bit
of uh here's a few minutes I think he
was on there for about 10 minutes but
here's a few minutes of Bill Barr
um speaking [__] that he should have
been saying a long time ago listen but I
mean when you
I think
I don't know if I would have approved
the indictment but in the sense I may
have exercised discretion and not gone
forward with the case uh I'm also
concerned about having this case going
on during the election and diverting
people's attention from the issues in
the election I'm also worried about you
know what the impact is if there are
acquittals uh during during the uh
campaign but as a legal matter I don't
see a problem with with the indictment I
think uh that uh it's not an abuse the
the Department of Justice is not acting
uh to weapon again one thing you notice
about Bill Barr in this little stupid
ditty he's doing here is
you notice he's saying uh a lot
and the reason why is because Bill Barr
is trying to be very careful about what
he says and what he doesn't say and the
reason why is because he doesn't just
want to tell the [__] truth
he doesn't just want to come out with it
and say what the [__] he should say
because he's a coward Bill Barr is a
coward he's always been a coward he
always will be a coward you can count on
it
absolutely 100 count on it
and he won't just say what he needs to
say in the public on television on
National cable TV what he needs to say
Donald Trump was trying to overthrow our
government I watched him do it
and he should have been saying this in
December when he resigned Bill Barr
should have resigned and should have
given a letter to the American people
saying the reason why I'm resigning is
because the president of the United
States is trying to get me to commit
Federal felonies to try to overthrow the
government
he should have said it out loud then not
just now you [__] scumbag
but I guess we'll take the consolation
prize recognize the department by
proceeding against the president for a
conspiracy uh to subvert the Electoral
the electoral process which is what
Trump's attorneys are saying and they're
also saying that he was just exercising
his his first amendment right here do
you think that's a valid argument in
your view no I really don't think that's
a valid argument because you know as the
indictment says you know he he they're
not attacking his first amendment right
he can say whatever he wants he can even
lie he can even tell people that uh that
uh the the election was was stolen when
he when he knew better but uh that does
not protect you from entering into a
conspiracy all conspiracies involve
speech and all fraud involves speech so
uh you know Free Speech doesn't give you
the right to engage in a fraudulent
conspiracy to overthrow the government
of the United States
again he's such a [__] weak coward
that he can't even say it out loud
um Gracie Gracie here was uh says on
YouTube says Barr was in on it bar
here's the thing Barr and Mike Pence
like I said before they absolutely were
in on the coup
until the point that they personally
reach criminal liability of federal
felonies
Bill Barr as a coward as he is he is not
dumb
he's not stupid Bill Barr knows the law
a lot of times he takes advantage of the
things he knows about the law
a lot of times he does
so Bill Barr knew when his own personal
ass would have been in a ringer with a
federal courts if he would have done and
said certain things as part of the coup
plot
they went right up to the line Mike
Pence the same way now I'm not going to
give Mike Pence
as much as as much leeway here on
knowing the law but his attorneys
certainly did we saw that in the January
6 elect hearings the evidence is there
his attorneys were trying to find this
information they were trying to find the
facts
and Mike Pence went right up to the line
of himself being in Libra legal Jeopardy
of going to prison for Donald Trump and
he stopped at that line and only now
only now
is Mike Pence willing to say that out
loud
they are [__] cowards
cowards cowards cowards
and that's the that's the fair truth of
it
that's the I mean Jesus Christ you look
at you you talk about cowards all
Republicans are cowards Mitch McConnell
won't even release a statement
and Mitch McConnell after voting to not
impeach Donald Trump the second time for
the coup went to the floor of the Senate
and said
that Donald Trump is not immune from
Criminal liability just because we don't
impeach him he said it out loud but he
won't say it today Mitch McConnell will
not double down on his statements he
will not well probably because he might
not be able to speak he may glitch
glitch McConnell
the point is this
is that they're all cowards Kevin
McCarthy when the coup happened Kevin
McCarthy went to the floor of the house
and said it's Donald Trump's fault and
it never should have happened and it was
an attempt at violence to overthrow our
country and now he's back to an
Insurrection never happened oh this is
all weaponization of the government it's
all fake it's not even real they're
cowards
because they're Republicans
they do not have a party of strength
anymore they really never did it was all
an illusion I told you this the other
day I showed you the clip of wrestling
ball
I showed you the clip it's always been
the Republican party has always been a
cult
always
and forever the Republican party has
been a cult they just didn't find their
cult leader yet
and they finally found their desperate
cult leader inside the buffoon Donald
Trump that's it that's all they did
that's that's why Bill Barr
stammers and dances around even now on
CNN and won't say it
because they're occult because the fact
Still Remains Bill Barr will vote for
Donald Trump and I say will because he
is going to be the nominee he's the
presumptive nominee there's no one going
to challenge him like Hal said his
supporters are going to get out and eat
their nuts off
it's not gonna happen Vivek or DeSantis
and there's no one else I guess will
heard the news is and at least Donald
Trump said this [__] will Herod
apparently dropped out of the race
because he can't he's gonna go nowhere
because he keeps saying the truth about
Donald Trump
you can't you can't speak the truth
about the cult leader to the cult
that's not how it's going to work that's
why I've been saying for months and
months and months trumps is going to be
their nominee because I understand how
Cults work now I said earlier that I
made the mistake
in 2016 with Trump I didn't mean I voted
for him I meant that I thought that he
couldn't win
that's what I meant
and now I know how he can win and how we
must fight it we did it in 2020 we did
it in 2022 this country did it we fought
back against trumpism we fought back
against the buffoonery we fought back
against their strategy of stupid and we
won yes did we lose the house but we
lost it by margins uh that were so
minuscule that only a few only a few
house races in 2024 and we will have
Hakeem Jeffries as the speaker of the
house and I think we can do much more
than that
I think we can win Senate seats take
these Republican incumbents and kick
them to the curb I believe we can win
back the house by resounding numbers
I definitely think we can take
governorships
100 can make make make moves and state
legislators all around the all around
the country
I believe it is possible 2022 proves it
doubt me
but we must have resolve we must stay
vigilant in our democracy
and we can't expect
someone
to save it for us it's just not how it
works just go back to 2016 When Donald
Trump stood on the stage and said only I
can fix it
oh let's see here well then
I get it
I wanna I had another clip I wanted to
show you where is it
where is it someone's talking about this
mask uh skeleton mask
um anyone I'll do the skeleton Mass
thing tomorrow I just don't know if I
have enough time and I to be honest I
haven't looked at it yet
yesterday was karaoke day what do you
want for me yesterday was karaoke day do
we have do we have any video of um
of Washington DC
by the way as I'm talking about tomorrow
um tomorrow we're we're going to have
Boston brine on for bonehead of the week
so don't forget tonight uh to vote for
bonehead of the week you can vote for
bonehead of the week right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast on the community
tab on YouTube
do not forget
to vote for bonehead of the week you can
also vote for it on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod we'll put the the poll up
over there once the Reds gets the
ability to do a poll
I gotta be honest once we get the
ability to do the pull-on threads I
probably I probably I probably won't
and you kick my ass I probably won't um
I probably won't
put the poll on uh Twitter anymore once
we get the ability to put it on threads
but we just don't have that ability yet
I don't think I haven't really uh
re-downloaded or updated threads is
there any updates Newton see this is the
thing I I [__] can't stand social
media
she said she's gonna kick my ass
tomorrow you can kick my ass tomorrow if
I don't do it all right
it's a great story it's funny I watched
some of it I watched some of them uh the
the the the resistor sleuths over on
Twitter they uh they outed this guy
who's supposed to be some sort of trump
military gay or something and he would
wear a mask in a video oh
apparently the guy does gay porn so
we'll show you that tomorrow we'll
expose him tomorrow the thousands of
viewers live
um
but uh what was I talking about oh yeah
I don't like social media I'm not a
social media fan I really I'm not that
great at it I don't know if you guys
noticed that I'm much better just
talking into the microphone way better
at talking into the microphone
um but here's the thing
threads I had Great Hopes for it but I'm
going to be quite honest
when you when you have this thing where
um you're not doing updates and you're
not getting to the heart of why people
would leave
with leave Twitter to go to threads then
you're not gonna you're not gonna last
very long uh okay so here here is a
video let's see
um is this the yeah this is from in
front of the courthouse here's a video
from DC when was this posted this was
two hours ago so I'm sure we're uh
pretty much up to speed here I believe
he's supposed to get a reigned at three
o'clock Eastern it'll probably be late
because Trump's always late this morning
DC is also dignitaries
all media
pretty much all media you see the media
tracks it doesn't look like any uh Trump
army or as I refer to him the the shirt
Army oh wait oh there it is there's the
image that I saw a while ago there look
there are two Trump Flags not American
flags not American flags two Trump flags
do you see that one problem that they're
having
that one problem that they're having
about their patriotism
is they hate this country they [__]
hate this country
they hate it he's like it's a hell hole
it's a [__] it's going to hell in a
handbasket they [__] hate it they
hate everything about America
okay
so put your American flags away and fly
your Trump flag so we can properly
identify you then
um oh okay Brenda says 4 P.M Eastern
that's what that that's why I got three
in my head because four Eastern is three
Central my time
it's probably why I had three in my head
someone asked earlier uh on the Discord
if you guys want the Discord is hopping
over there if you want to go join our
Discord I'll put that link in the um
I'll put that link down below but if you
want to join our Discord the the chat is
hopping over there
um and someone asked the question
earlier if I was going to
extremely arraignment which there's not
going to be anything really to stream I
mean other than me just sitting here
talking telling you what I'm going to
tell you tomorrow about the arraignment
and if there's any footage like Trump or
statements afterwards I mean I'll I'll
definitely cover those tomorrow
um but I mean there's not going to be he
literally that fat ass is going to walk
in the courthouse they're going to
process it let me tell you it's going to
go he's going to walk into Courthouse
he's going to self-surrender the U.S
Marshals are going to take him
to the uh
um the processing room they're going to
do digital Fingerprints of him like they
said they would they're going to do
digital fingerprints they're not going
to do a picture I doubt they'll take any
DNA
of Donald Trump at that time they
already have his DNA more than likely
they know who he is they know a picture
of him
um yeah I I I posted I think it's in the
chat now yeah I posted the Discord Link
in the chat so if you want to get on
Discord and it's hopping over there like
several hundred people have joined just
in the last few days it's crazy over
there but here's the thing so I'm going
to ask if I would stream it and I'm not
really going to stream it because you're
not going to see anything there's no
cameras in the courtroom there's not
going to be any cameras allowed in the
courtroom they'll probably have a sketch
artist so we'll see a sketch there will
be a there will be a courtroom
photographer to take
photos of the history so we have that to
capture but there won't be any cameras
there won't be any footage there won't
be a live feed
that's the other thing too that the
media is doing that I keep telling you
stop listening to these [__] people
when they say this crazy [__] when
they're keep saying oh we need to have
cameras we need to push to have cameras
in the courtroom what who is we
listen we do not control a judge's
courtroom
and really honestly we should not get
used to pressuring a federal judge into
doing what are bidding that is not what
the justice system is designed to do
okay that's not Justice we're not this
is not a [__] mob in a pitch Port
pitch a pitchfork mob I trust this judge
this judge has uh
mountains of Integrity this judge is
wildly better than judge Cannon down in
the D or excuse me the documents case in
South Florida could ever dream
of having she has way more credibility
way way I'm way more impeccable record
than Canon could ever dream of hammock
Cannon has destroyed a record at this
point so I'm I'm going to trust what
this judge does
now the problem with that is if the
judge doesn't make a decision that
helps my narrative
I'm still gonna have to accept it
because it is going to be that that's
why I keep telling you stop listening to
people who are giving you hypotheticals
that are not likely that are just
getting your hopes up because if you get
your hopes up you might get discouraged
and discouragement
turns into self-suppression when you're
talking about the ballot and it's
dangerous it's dangerous stuff we have
to stay vigilant in our democracy so the
fact why the problem is is that I won't
have anything to stream this afternoon
it'll just me be talking
about the arraignment which I can talk
about tomorrow on the show I'm live
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Facebook page go
follow us over there on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels also you can watch live on
Twitch tomorrow me talk about the
arraignment process that isn't going to
be recorded tomorrow just the news
because the the most interesting thing
and the most
um the thing that we will go through
tomorrow is the clips of the response of
the arraignment because now he will be
arrested he will be arraigned and he
would have and he will pled not guilty
to the charges in open court
so tomorrow we will have those facts
today we don't yet have those facts we
don't have those things in front of us
so tomorrow we will so tomorrow we will
go through this and we will talk about
but I want to show you once again this
is the video but this is a freeze frame
of all look at all the TR look at the
chart Army there in Washington look at
all these people trying to defend Donald
Trump
from the deep State oh my god he has
such big support doesn't he holy [__] oh
my God
it's gonna be wild this arraignment
today Gonna Be Wild Charlie Kirk told us
we would regret doing this I don't know
do we regret doing this when this is the
imagery two flags two Trump Flags not
even an American flag
hmm
seems like I don't regret it
and neither should you I want to thank
Hal Sparks for being on again tomorrow's
bone of the week our special guest host
tomorrow tomorrow is Boston Brian damn
someone just pointed out we have over
1100 thumbs up today 100 1100 likes on
the video so keep liking and as you
leave don't forget to hit the like
button or the dislike button I don't
care but what you really need to do is
hit subscribe so tomorrow you can watch
bone of the week with the guest co-host
of bone end of the week Boston Brian
tomorrow on the Tony Michaels podcast
tomorrow same time same place
Surfs Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
foreign